tiger woods sharing a statement on
twitter tonight
thanking everyone for the support after
he was seriously hurt in a crash this
morning
he is awake and recovering at a southern
california hospital
we thank you for joining us at 11 i'm
brian loftis and i'm denise valdez so we
have learned more over the last few
hours including the severity of those
leg injuries
which required plates and screws now as
for the accident firefighters were
forced to pull
woods out of the front windshield first
responders saying his seat
belt saved his life chris martinez
shares more from los
angeles tiger woods remains hospitalized
after a rollover crash in suburban los
angeles tuesday morning
the front end was totally destroyed the
bumpers everything was destroyed
airbags deployed all of that the
interior was more or less intact which
kind of gave him
the cushion to survive what's otherwise
would have been a fatal crash
firefighters had to pry the vehicle open
to get woods out
carlos gonzalez was the first sheriff's
deputy on the scene mr woods was
seated in the driver's seat he told me
his name was tiger at that moment i
immediately recognized him
first responders said the golf legends
injuries were serious but not
life-threatening
his agent later said woods underwent
surgery on both legs
we're looking at signs of influence
under the influence of either narcotics
medication
alcohol odor of alcohol all these
different things that would give you an
idea in their behavior but there was not
none present the cause of this crash
remains
unknown it's the third high profile
incident involving tiger woods
and a vehicle in 2009 he drove into a
fire hydrant and a tree outside his
florida mansion
eight years later woods was charged with
dui after being found asleep at the
wheel of a parked car
it hurts to see one of your i mean now
my closest friends
you know getting an accident and man i
just hope he's alright
woods recently underwent back surgery
and hoped to return to the lynx
sometime this spring the 45 year old has
won
15 major tournaments during his career
second
on the all-time list chris martinez cbs
news los angeles
late tonight we heard more on his
condition for the first time through a
statement on twitter
it described open fractures to both the
tibia and the fibula
and injuries to the bones foot and ankle
it also reads that he is currently awake
responsive and recovering in his
hospital room there are no further
updates at this time